sahpresa lien entre leur mini sur
catalogue ces femmes mal on est un
maniaque de pêche qui nous montre avec
fierté sa toute nouvelle embarcation un
zodiac qui n'a rien à voir avec sa
chaloupe de 16 pieds avec laquelle il a
navigué pendant des années à la
présentait tout cas bateau l'os
je l'aimé comme ça se prépare elle est
vendue capable de changer le barça sera
exploité en paient le prix de fou audace
entre deux bateaux moi je suis recherché
il ya deux là quand même eu des péchés
j'ai pas d'accès parce que je
poursuivrai c'est très dommage je paye
des taxes le numéro un européen des
tacles et pas que c'est pas normal ils
sont nombreux comme lui a déploré cette
situation c'est comme un râteau autres
le brevet jacques vadeboncoeur est un
habitué des plans d'eau depuis plus de
50 ans au début des années 80 deux mains
sûres de te grattes plutôt mal partout
avoir un terrain rendu un prix exact
1.4 à votre pire en pire
je vous dirais que canto de montréal
c'est presque 90% des accès se sont
rendus payants il ya plusieurs villes
qui interdit l'accès aux non résidents
d'autres villes interdisent
l'utilisation de moteurs essence
d'autres villes comme charge 394 en
lavant 500 dollars par jour stéphane
bourgeois milite depuis plus de dix ans
pour améliorer l'accessibilité au plan
d'eau mais l'enjeu est complexe
en général tous les plans d'eau de la
province sous juridiction provinciale et
fédérale
mais ce sont les municipalités qui en
gère l'accès m'a raconté ce n'est pas
sain c'est vrai il ya des conflits
d'usagé les résidents qui va de
tranquillité déjà des plaisanciers et
l'autre vont faire du bruit de la
musique dans le tapis puis enfin la
vague puis des pêcheurs que nous on est
comme plus tranquille
concilier tout le monde ici à rosemère
l'afflux de plaisanciers au cours de la
dernière année a poussé le maire a
privatisé les deux accès à la rivière
des mille-îles sur son territoire du
parc charbonneau ici qui est un superbe
endroit se fait envahir les gens pique
nique les gens et les gens avec des
embarcations
la chance du compte que toutes les
embarcations à moteur haut niveau
biodiversité au niveau gestion d'érosion
dérivés tout ça c'est très mauvais pour
l'environnement la protection des lacs
est aussi au coeur de cet enjeu des
municipalités sont très frileuses use
espèces exotiques envahissantes
ils veulent avoir le moins possible
d'étrangers sur le lac
nous ce qu'on leur dise c'est que oui on
est conscient qu'on peut transporter des
espèces exotiques envahissantes mais il
faut prendre les moyens pour laver des
embarcations en costard que tout le
monde devrait avoir accès à l'eau la
mairesse de notre dame de l'île perrot a
inauguré la semaine dernière la première
rampe de mise à l'eau publique et
accessible aux non résidents la seule
sur son territoire et il a fallu douze
ans c'est assez compliqué à avoir une
autorisation aujourd'hui en deux
21 tout simplement parce que les normes
environnementales ont beaucoup changé
mais aussi les exigences les villes font
face à un défi financier alors ça prend
beaucoup d'investissement pour pour
gérer une descente à l'eau se trompe lui
a coûté au final près de 80 mille
dollars
parce que vous aimerez québec justement
dans le coup de main ben c'est sûr
c'est certain que l'aide du gouvernement
serait serait la bienvenue parce que
c'est un service à la population en
général et donc ça serait ce serait très
apprécié comment cohabiter sur les plans
d'eau le gouvernement de la kia qui
avait promis en campagne électorale de
s'attaquer au problème
pour stéphane la solution est simple il
faut réapprendre à partager les plans
d'eau la mentalité des livres et c'est
mon lac toba d'avril
ça fait partie de la crise est partout
partout des lots ici marie michèle osant
radio canada montréal